let's get into this uh william what drew
you to the story and drew you to coming
into a a franchise that was essentially
you know starting from the second one
well i was a fan of the first one
already like kind of a super fan of the
first one and um i'd studied it to
become kind of a student of the movie in
a way
and um
and there was a script that gave me the
script and
uh i was
you know suspect that it would be good
enough and live up to the original the
original had such a great twist among
other things
and the script totally
delivered and i was surprised and then
the next question was hmm like how could
we ever
like how do we bring back isabelle
into this character because who could
ever feel her shoes so that became kind
of the the big question
because she specifically was amazing as
a child you know when she did the
original film and isabelle you were an
actual child the first time you played
esther and now you're coming back and
you're an actual adult
so can you talk a little bit about how
it was different to return to the role
as an adult yeah i think it definitely
rounded out you know the character a lot
more i mean when i was a kid i remember
i did so much research on you know body
language of adults and watched my mom
and her friends and vera on set and just
was trying to kind of get into the
mindset of like what is it exactly that
women kind of how do they hold
themselves how are they and now being
an adult it was like the opposite i was
sitting there watching
and sadie who were my body doubles every
single day and just being like how do i
take some of this childlike
quality that they have this bounciness
that i had when i was a kid and bring it
back in into this character because
um in a sense you know
through my head i'm thinking oh it's so
much easier this time around because i'm
not a kid pretending to be an adult
who's passing herself off as a kid i'm
just an adult having to play another a
kid
but
i really felt like my experience this
time around mirrored that of lena's
experience trying to fit herself back
into this family trying to become master
i really felt like it was it was a
discovery and every single day i was
learning things from brent i was
learning things from sadie and kennedy
it was learning things from my old
script and the notes that i had made
when i was 10 um but i i really felt
like confident in the fact that i could
do it i could
step back into her shoes and like
recreate this character but i think
there was also a conscious effort to try
and not try and mimic exactly what i did
in the first movie find her again find
who she is and then bring something new
to it and i think we did that
really well william i know that there
was some talk about
not bringing um isabelle back to play
esther
and you fought for her can you talk a
little bit about
what the reasoning
behind
not bringing her back would have been
and just like i personally can't see
anybody playing esther
and
it seems ridiculous but you know no i
hear you and
i think at first just because so much
time had gone by i had no idea if she
ever you know if she would have been
like you're crazy i'm not going to
pretend to be a kid in the movie you
know she may have said that if i would
have asked her directly she actually
approached me sort of
and and then she was like so passionate
about the fact that this is my character
i just want you to know and if there's
any way we can make it work i want to
keep telling her story
and i was like wow that's that's the
biggest
hurdle is her like genuinely wanting to
do it
and um
so for me then it was it was just like
that's because that's the hardest part
like it's lightning in a bottle to find
a kid like she was in
2008
um
that could do that that could play that
kind of character
and then it's such a specific character
she's so iconic that it was very
difficult for me to imagine anybody else
and certainly
hindsight impossible in any way to
imagine anybody else because we were
able to do it and then once we get into
doing it
you know there were so many small
nuances
and aspects of the character that she
could do that it would have it you know
it just
i agree with you you know it just would
never have been the same thing and um
you know which is what's cool about
doing it once
means that if we ever wanted to do it
again we can do it again you know it's
like it's she'll never grow out of the
character
um it's really but about you know her
like if she wants to do it right but um
and then and then getting it getting it
approved or whatever it took us about
you know on and off
like nearly a year
of of tests and
and
a lot of conversations and a lot of
spitballing and brainstorming and um
and then ultimately you know
the final test we did where she actually
came in and dressed up like esther for
the first time in a decade i guess
um
and it was kind of a nutty little shoot
that
you know it it did its job you know it
allowed us to kind of tell the story
with her as a character again and it was
and that was it then we were off to the
races and making the movie together
which was i actually like dm'd
brent when he got signed on to be the
director and i went to his boy premiere
party because i was like
i have to stand in front of him so he
sees that it's not that crazy of an idea
that i could come back because
you know obviously you grow up but my my
i always joke like i grew into my face
like my face was always a little bit
bigger than the rest of my body i was
like i still have the same face
and it didn't i mean it seemed natural
that
you would if you're playing
if you're an adult you know if you're
playing
you know
you know i was talking to the director
of photography and he made a good point
and i don't know that we ever even
talked about this but he said
he's like in this movie
she looks probably more like she should
have looked in the first movie like
because this is really who she is you
know she's this petite ultra petite
um youthful looking adult
and um
so
yeah it's pretty crazy and uh isabel you
were an associate producer on this film
um
did that come with any kind of
um extra
like what did that entail for you i
think it was more so just being
creatively involved in more aspects of
bringing her back and i think
you know we just brett and i just had
way more of a collaborative i would say
conversations about things to bring from
the last movie into this one
whether that was like articles of
clothing or
even things that we wanted to do with
the doubles with kennedy and sadie you
know it was more like i got to be
creatively involved in not just you know
the creation of this character but like
how do we
how do we create something new and fresh
together and you know it
i i've never played that role before
being an associate producer it was
definitely like learning every single
day but i i just felt like i was
involved in the movie from the very
beginning in the sense that
i had talked to david leslie johnson our
executive producer before the movie even
kind of got put together and it was a
conversation of whether or not i could
come back and play esther how i could
creatively be involved as a consultant
things like that so i think in any way i
would have probably been been involved
in some capacity but to be able to
reprise this role as well as be involved
in some of the you know creative choices
and be able to collaborate with brent
and with alex and
david and everyone really it was just
such a cool experience to have and for
this movie too i mean this was the first
film that i did when i was a kid so to
come back
to this like family it was really
special and i'll tell you
for me um
in that respect
once we started really working together
and then there were questions in the
script that i was like i'm not sure if i
you know i would just ask her i would go
what do you think what would esther do
and you would you know isabelle would be
like no way
or i would never say that great okay and
um and then watching her with the devils
you know it's like i would kind of
direct isabel in what the scene was um
we'd work on that and then when the
doubles came in i'd step back and she
would direct the doubles
and um you know because they had to do
exactly what she was doing and it was
very cool very cool to watch and brent
you're kind of known as a hard director
what is it about the genre that draws
you to it
i think it's um
it's so creative you know we we get a
lot of fair amount of freedom
to do we want to do in different ways
and
i mean stephen king said we create
horrors to help us deal with the real
ones and i've always really liked that
quote
so with a
with a horror film you know you can
sometimes sneak in really great social
commentary or um
dealing with certain
problems in your own life or others uh
through the story you know when it's all
wrapped up in a fun sometimes bloody
ride but um
you know it's still like a great forum
to tell great stories with great
characters and like this
is a perfect example that there is some
reality to this one i mean
which is what's even crazier
yeah
is there really have you like heard
about a case of a
woman pretending to be a little girl oh
yeah that was kind of what spawned the
like
i guess taking the script out again i
mean they they had written the script
for this prequel uh a year or two before
um and then i sat down with david leslie
johnson just to have a coffee and was
like have you ever thought of making a
prequel or a sequel he was like actually
we have a prequel and he sent me the
script and it was around the time that
there was this huge story on dr phil
about this young this family that had
adopted a child and then they thought
that she was an adult and she had
threatened to kill them so they bought
her an apartment and just like left her
and i actually don't even i haven't
looked it up and i probably should but
the ending to that story
but
it was everywhere everyone was talking
about orphan and that was kind of i told
david i was like you have to take the
script out now because i've never had
more people in my life message me about
the movie than right now and really it
kind of like everything really ramped up
came together brent came on in 2019 like
that all happened in the time span of
like a month or two and then
and then it was like how do we make this
work and
now here we are so there is there is
some reality to it definitely yeah there
are several stories like this out there
yeah and there's one hulu just picked up
a whole tv show about it there was uh
what's it called there was a story when
we were filming the original i mean
there is there is something to be said
about life imitating art wow
that's crazy
i don't know that she goes and
systematically kills the family one by
one you know that kind of thing in the
real world stories i'm not sure though
it's different it's totally you know
we've got also an element of uh romance
i would say kind of yeah
well you know what are you guys working
on what do you have coming up oh gosh uh
i just i've done a bunch of things i
have a movie called shiro's that
actually paramount is going to be
putting out i don't know when but soon
um and then it's a like an action comedy
movie totally different from this i
actually get to be funny in it um and
then i did a just did a sci-fi film as
well called little mouth with josh
hutcherson was the first time i worked
with him since i did hunger games
and uh i also did a film with don
johnson earlier this year um and andy
tennant directed it so i
i'm i'm working i'm having a great time
i'm really lucky so thank you esther for
coming back to my life
and i just i'm just finishing up a movie
i shot in london called lord of miss
rule um which is like a pagan horror
film
um and we're locking picture like next
week you know or we're finalizing color
and sound next week
so
you know
i'm ready for that ready to wrap that up
all right well thank you so much you
guys it was a really i really enjoyed
the film i was a little nervous about it
because you know how can you talk the
first but i really really enjoyed it
that's great thank you so much
thank you so much